ok welcome thank you
so much for joys
special
event
What a perfect day
to spend rainy fried
afternoong
this the
call to the talkon
Wednesday
I'm professor
doctow
professor amerides
of history
and curly professor
of
alogy
at the
stay
to [ __ ] light on
korean history
culture art  and
religion in the
grator is agen and
you rasion context
[laughter]
[music]
Today, for the second time, I'm going to
talk about Korean culture and ideology.
As you can see on the map, the
arena of our national activities right now is the Korean Peninsula and the
Manchurian era, so
of course, in our culture, the
northern nomadic culture in the grassland
comes down, so this
is LG Keith,
and on the right
is the Kaiga culture like this
Taiga forest  In culture, and in
the west, there is the culture of China.
China
I think that people who live in this ecological environment have
different personalities and
different lifestyles.  The place where the
grassland culture of the north, the forest culture of the north, the
agricultural culture of China, and the
maritime culture of the far south were mixed in the territory
is where our people were born and developed.
Personally, I think
we have lived in or have the most perfect ecological environment on this planet.
So, in this environment,
Korean
living culture has no choice but to show diversity.
Zone
[laughter] It's
temperate, but it's
got a lot of different climates from north to south,
and gramprenslah
intromistypt
arious
have the ariouseuns
down,
so you're eating the kimchi on the right.  It
can be explained, but I think it is a kind of
fermentation culture. There is a
food that many people around the world like, and
this is soybean paste.  There is no choice but to
have the right culture, thoughts and ideas.
This building is a traditional Korean building, and
even now, there are still such traditional houses in Jeonju, Jeolla-do, called Hanok Village.
Korea has a unique residential culture, and the
heating system ondol culture has developed.
In , there
is a floor like this along with ondol.  I'll
tell you about thought, faith, and belief. I
talked about it last time, but many people
misunderstand that there were no ideas, beliefs, or learning in ancient Korea.
Confucianism, which came into Confucianism at the time,
did not have a big impact.
I also ask you a question. There
was a country until the 3rd century AD, and
there was no history, belief, or ideology of that country.  I
'm sure. I'm looking for such evidence
along with some kind of historical record, along with many
relics, and in the folklore that remains among the Korean people.
Of course, Shamaism remains in Eastern Siberia,
Baikal, and the Pamir region where I am.
If you want to know about these things at a good university, it
is simple if you invite me.
And why do we have to have this kind of
thought?
Korea's mountains and rivers The characteristic of
these things is that there is also the sky.  It
has no choice but to be a tradition,
and in this natural environment, there
is no choice but to have a strong sense of community. So,
Koreans think that all Koreans are one family.
As a historian, I
have studied not only historical facts but also ideas, and I
have presented you about human civilization and, as you can see, I have
written many books here.
Yes, because they exist for the future. Andes
Light and
I, including my wife and sons and daughters, are
important, Korean
people are important, American people are
important, and even humanity as a
whole is important.
This is a
new theory by Dr. Yoon.
However, in the past, we were not very happy, but we were
very sad and quiet, and we
noticed others and learned it wrong that way.
It is not true, and
Korean people
In the history of East Asia, we are the only
Koreans who have maintained their legitimacy to the end for more than 3,500 years.
That's why we
have a strong display.  It is
not the country of the morning, but the
country of the dynamic sun. Have
you ever seen a word like this? Of course,
this is a
word I coined.  It's only
Joseon
pairing.
On top of that, there's 3000 years of time. To
understand Korea, to understand Korea's genetic character,
you have to look at it not just 500 years
ago, but even before that.
[Music]  I think you've
understood everything,
so I was invited by the world's best
East Asian researcher at
Yale University.
But Goguryeo, contrary to what many people
think, is in fact culturally related to today's
Central Asian region.
In fact, I
highly value Japanese culture and
like Japan. I
really think so.
On the contrary, it is a fact of history that the people who came from the Korean Peninsula
lived in the area,
built the country, and developed the culture.
These are the founding myths of Japan.  Everyone knows this because it's so obvious when you
look at the relics and other things in the tombs.
From now on, I
'll show you a fun picture.  The
first and second capitals of Goguryeo are
currently located in Manchuria, not on the
Korean Peninsula.  It
has a strong structure.
I'll tell you a word here.
European
castles and Japanese castles are very big and beautiful in China.
But Korean castles are
big, but not beautiful and
not clear. There
is a reason our
Korean castles are castles that
protect the people.
Gratitude is not to protect the ruling class.
The results in Europe are different, but in terms of my
values ​​and my outlook on life, I
think it is more valuable because it is a surname that really fought for the people in the words of Gogun's surname in our nation.
Would you have a new idea
about our Korean culture with today's opportunity?
The Chinese have investigated, but there are about 12,000
ancient texts like this in
this
area.  Let me
tell you one thing, this is a
Goguryeo ruler, 100 feet.
So,
coring stew,
Goguryeo,
and an equilateral triangle.
And here, there are
seven books of seven.  It's my
favorite
number ands
Koreans love the
most
In Korea, when a child is born, they think it's
not just a child, it's the birth of the universe.
That's why they do various rituals.  It's
important,
so the first of our people is the
Dangun myth and the founding myth
is structured like this.
Let's move on to the answer to the
foundation.  There
is an army armed with technology.
Here, 259 soldiers are drawn.
And these are
soldiers armed with iron. They are cavalrymen. And there are golden
arrowheads
and stirrups.  It's
pretty, but please pay attention to the clothes,
I know the
faces.
It's different from the Hanbok of the Joseon Dynasty. It
has the clothes of former fighting warriors like in the Amazon on
horseback.  These are bows made earlier. In
fact, I went in several times and
saw these things myself.
That is not our land now, but
I have a plan to go to the land of
Goguryeo and suddenly climb again.
[Laughs]
Koreans have long forgotten this culture of riding horses,
and they have
lost their strong spirit and strong free will.  It
was played in the newspaper,
so I will give an example. There are
such contents in the valuable and thin e-book file.
Especially Korean-speaking students will find it
very interesting to read this book.
You can think of it as a phoenix.
When you
see this picture of a bird, do you feel droopy or do you
feel a strong force?
However, with these footprints, I hold the reality tightly with my claws. I
judge that I drew this type of painting because I have always lived in the world aiming for an ideal.
You talk about it a lot, but the problem
is time. These are the
golden crowns of Baekje.
Again Baekje gold crowns
And another one
And
shoes
and shoes
And again
light
and
mole creation This will
briefly tell you how related Eurasia and our Korean people are.
This is the Oasis Road called the Silk Road.
But there are so many roads.
Of course, Korean culture is very related to Central Asia like this.
Such
evidence first appears in the language. It is
generally called Altaic.  It is
denied
Everyone,
like this, the
kings of Altaiga call themselves khans,
and there are many countries with the name of Korea.
There is such a Korea, but
especially after Genghis Khan, many countries
call themselves Korea.  There
was Korea and
now the name of Korea is Korea. It
is important in Antray Korea and the sky is called Tangle.
The people of Turkus in Neighborhood
call Hando Tangle, and they maintain the belief of Tangleism
to this day.
But there are many places.  I'll go ahead and
give one example.
Where is the most severe war in the Eurasian world right now?
And the great sea beneath it is called the
Black Sea.
And the
black sea was so bad that it was
difficult to make breakfast even though it was a big ship. And
the sea was black and
the seathe, so it
has the name black sea.
In Japan, it is called
Kuro. So
many
key words are right in the middle  It is connected
to the Asian Altizer and our Japanese Yuldo. At
one end of the mask in Samarkand, Uzbekistan, Central Asia, where I am,
there is a mural of a king around the 7th century.
In the midst of a war for 20 years, the
West
sent diplomatic missions to Samarkand, which is 4,000 km away. It's quite
surprising.
Hey, it's
not a joker, it's real. In
Korea, in a city called Guri-si, right next to Seoul,
there's a statue of the Audience Foundation modeled after me. As
you know, I'm a
historian, so I
do everything based on documentary evidence.
Actually yes
wait and ah now it's almost
over
Religion and
faith What are these things?
Especially in the Altai region of Central Asia, they
worship the sky. This is called Tengri
faith.
And when it crosses the sea, the
same story is said in Japan.
So, if you look at the Japanese flag,
there is the sun.
Haemosu. And you
can float the picture on the raft I rode on.
Others, then bird, then
cosmic mountain.
Joe And
also the same Cosmic Tree These things are
shared by Siberia or Eurasia Korea.
Of course, in Manchuria and the Korean Peninsula, their
own Chongdong-gyu culture has developed since 2000
BC.  The
Chongdong culture comes in. The ski time culture is that the
Scythians are related to the development of our nation's chonchon and culture. I
will show you such evidence
and these things are Persian glass.
A lot of Persian-derived glass products
are found in
this.  It
was discovered in Silla, there
is only one of us, and there
is only one like this on Earth. Oh
increands,
why was this discovered in
Gyeongju?  This
is a model of a cup made of horns from which people drank.
And in our Silla,
many Central Asian people are found.
So, our ancient Korea
was active in doctrine and accepted the teachings of each other through various channels with the Eurasian world.
I'll give it to you. There
's an age of booing in Japan. Now
bcc, usually,
it's an ancient Japanese culture that usually started in the 4th century BC.
So, at this time, Japan started cultivating rice,
using metal weapons, and
starting to form a nation.
Then, when Japan came, it lived.  Where did the residents
cross over? Are they
flying? They have no choice but to go by boat.
So there are not many Jomon people who had an outstanding culture that was only a little in the Japanese tropics.
From the 4th century, from the
4th century, Japan
began to create its own countries.
So, contrary to the opinion of many Koreans,
I argue that from the 4th century, Japan's
tomb culture developed tremendously and its
economic power was excellent.  I have
already revealed enough through my book
and now this is the end.
Not the end of the lecture, but intron in relations with Japan.  The
refugees cross over to the Japanese archipelago,
and again, the
refugees from Goguryeo also land in the Japanese tropics,
and finally in 670, everyone
joins forces to build a new country, and the
country established at that time is Japan.
Japan is the most
fundamental place where the sun rises So, I
will show you that Korea and Japan have so many similarities in ancient times.
There are many stories here related to America, but they go too far.
At the end of World War II, there
was a hide-and-seek game between the U.S. Army and the Japanese military,
which was between Japan trying to hide these three important
treasures and the
U.S. trying to find them.  I
judge it to be a strong country. Gilt-
bronze shoes found in Japan Gilt-
bronze shoes found in Korea What are you doing?  It is
clear that Japan is a powerful country, but once
again, Japan
is a more powerful country than we thought.  An
ancient nation will be completed. A helmet
discovered in Korea, Andison, a gold-
bronze crown found in Japan, a gold-bronze crown found in Japan,
this is important.
Gilt-bronze, Japan's National Treasure
No.  I went to and saw this Buddha statue,
but look to the left.
This is an important fact. I'm
going to omit it.
Now I'm going to talk about Manchuria. And the
Northwest Manchuria region that we know, and it's
very much influenced by the nomadic culture that came down from the north,
and even Central Asia.
So,
of course, these
East Asia has an unavoidable dynamic
relationship. There
are nomadic cultures in the grasslands that lead to prosperity,
and on the other side, there is a huge
civilization and
state in China. These
two powers are always in conflict.  There
was Eastern civilization in the East,
but
essation is geopolitically also a
life of sin.
So, if the Chinese power is strong, of course, the
Northern power and our Eastern power have
no choice but to have a friendly relationship.
Chinese people do not like to admit it, but
in fact, many parts of Chinese history are
filled with the conquered nations of the Seonbi and the Geotans.
However, according to the records of Chinese history books in the middle of the 6th century, the words of
Sunbi, the words of Georan, and Buyeo, the
predecessor of our Goguryeo  It is written that the words are the same.
These things suggest a very important aspect. It
is in eastern Manchuria and it
is the
Qing Dynasty. Country Kingdom
And then, looking at it, we
need to revisit East Asian history.
I think it's very great
because it's a deliberately center, so it's
where all the people and all the cultures in Asia come together.
And in fact, Jeong Cheol has
so many conquered countries that they built,
so I
came up with a theory.
China is a
concept of culture, society, and geography,
not a concept of a country.
Chinese culture is really great, but we also need to know that it is a composite work of many people. So Chinese culture is now East Asian
culture is the so-called Han Chinese, and the
Mongoloids in the east, and the Turks in the west,
and all  Together, we
now need to create a new order in East Asia.
Now, I'm almost telling you the epilogue.
Korea is an old historical community with almost no influence on the planet.
I
told you enough in the first class. If
you are new to today, be sure to
ask other friends about the lecture I gave last time.
[Music]
And as I
said last time, I
'm looking at the East Asian Mediterranean,
and our Korean national anthem is  It
is a land-based country that organically combines land and sea.
Crea
I see that China is now also aiming to become a land-based
country. China, of course, was not a
maritime
country.  I'm having a conflict with the maritime United States or
Japan or Southeast Asian countries.
As for this [music] part, I
wrote enough in one book that everything was perfectly
important.
[Music] I have a lot of affection
for Korea because I am a Korean.
Korea has a unique ecological environment
and
has a meaningful ideology, culture and Jesus.  They
have a different culture and different thoughts and ideas from China or Japan.
So,
Koreans have lost good ideas about Korea as of now.
And I hope that we will use
Korea's historical and cultural
ideas as a good tool to solve the problems facing humanity.
That's why I'm here.
I wonder why you use the terms Manchuria and Manchurian region. Goguryeo
had its capital in Manchuria for 400 years. Goguryeo
and the birthplace of our Korean people are Manchuria and the
northern part of the Korean Peninsula.  There
is an argument in Goguryeo about how to know the difference,
but when you look at the international environment at the time and all these
evidences, you are more
certain.  Please
enter the question section, everyone,
some people say that history is the past and the
present is the present,
but
how would you explain to these people that history is the present and the present is important?
History is futurology. This is my
proposition.
So,
history is an indicator of how humans will live in the future. It is a
criterion. That's
okay.  The castle has a unique structure. The
first wife has a castle to protect the elite, and
then the rest
spreads out to protect the entire population.
This is the characteristic of Goguryeo. The
history of Goguryeo is the history of our ordinary people,
not the history of a minority ruling class.
Among the prejudice against Korea,
what do you think is the most problematic prejudice?
Koreans are the Hanhye people.
It seems that
Japanese culture is
at least
the best in the world for very old watches. You
can find Jomong earthenware from the Jomong period in Ulsan, Busan, Korea, and tools made of black elements, which you know well.
And recently, the
blood of the Jomong people  It
was discovered in the southern part of the Korean Peninsula.
However, Korean people
not only do not admit it, but do not know. This is a
real problem.
Hallyu
Hollywood I
don't necessarily see it positively.
Our exchange rate now is heavily influenced by Western culture.
That mountain stream,
but originally, what we did in ancient times
was very good and desirable.
[Music] It's a
really difficult question. We have to
unify because we're actually one ethnic community.
I think
humans are only biological genes.  It
claims that there are also historical genes. It is
a theory. Historical genes So,
unification is necessary so that we can create a normal society.
For now, we must first pursue a state in which the South and the North coexist peacefully,
and we must
create historical interpretations and theories that can create a community as one of them.
I asked the king of when the Korean people
will be unified.
This is what
I had to say.
No one can predict international relations.
But after 10 years, the
predictions are half wrong.
Religion or people of faith make prophecies, but
historians only function as predictions.  A
community of people who live their lives,
I believe, is in that region.
Destiny is more.
It's the
kids
[Music]
I'm here today to find out for myself a new model of human civilization, to see it in
detail, to
touch it.
After I finished the lecture the day before yesterday, the
content of this lecture was
published in a very large newspaper in Korea.  It
would have been an article.
I am grateful to all of you. It is
very rewarding for me that you
listened to my lectures so earnestly and actively after a while
and asked many questions.
Why is America important?
All people and all cultures  Everything is
gathered,
of course, so you
can find a new future for mankind here.
Currently, there is only a space where you can do that.
You guys
[Applause]
[Music]